[Music]
Scottish City Glasgow once held a grim
title the murder capital of Europe the
homicides in the city have fallen by 60%
in just over a decade
all thanks to a radical approach
treating violence as a disease here's
how Scotland is curing violent crime
growing levels of alcohol abuse
unemployment and inequality between the
1980s and early 2000s had contributed to
a social crisis in Scotland by 2005 the
crime rate had reached its highest
levels in a decade and the United
Nations released a report which named
Scotland is the most violent place in
the developed world but it was in
Scotland's largest city Glasgow where
the problem was most severe lately I can
anticipate around a dozen calls for gang
fighting on the street I grip the shot
at oh say somebody's home this high
concentration of gang violence and push
cars goes murder eight almost three
times higher than the rest of the
country but in 2005 in response to the
growing crisis garze goes regional
police force set up the violence
reduction unit or VRU it became the only
police force in the world to take a
public health approach to violence that
meant treating violence as a preventable
disease rather than just as a criminal
matter the VI used new strategy was
inspired by the work of Garry slacking
an American physician who'd spent a
decade fighting cholera and aids
epidemics across Africa during the 80s
and 90s when he came back to Chicago
Slatkin was confronted with another
epidemic of gun violence after mapping
crime data he noticed that violence
followed the same patterns as contagious
diseases one act led directly to another
and these were often found clustered
together he also found that violence
could be transmitted between people if a
person was exposed to violence it
increased the likelihood that they would
commit violence in 2000 [ __ ] King
created a pilot project on the west side
of Chicago which controlled outbreaks of
violence in a similar way to health
epidemics
focuses on three key areas first to find
the cause of an outbreak and interrupt
its transmission to other people this
work is carried out by violence
interrupters people with an established
relationship with the community who can
help identify symptoms and eliminate the
root causes of violence second is to
identify people who might be at risk of
developing violent behavior and try to
prevent it from happening this is done
by offering alternatives to gang
membership through employment housing
and health support finally an important
step is to change attitudes towards
violence making communities understand
that it's something preventable not
inevitable this approach has been
adapted by the violence reduction unit
in Scotland but as well as helping
people break free from violence the VIU
has also advocated for stronger
penalties for those who continue on a
path of crime through lobbying the
penalty for carrying a knife in Scotland
has tripled in ten years by 2006
Scotland had extended the work of the
VRU nationwide and during the following
decade violent crime fell by 49 percent
including murders which were reduced by
47 percent these dramatic reductions
have helped to ease the burden on the
Scottish health care system with
hospital emergency of salt admissions
down by 56 percent since 2007 and the
benefits of a reduced crime rate or
economic to each homicide case in the UK
is estimated to cost the taxpayer 2.3
million dollars which is more than the
cost of running the VRU for an entire
year while Scotland is aiming to achieve
the lowest levels of crime in the world
by 2025 at the other end of the country
London has seen a recent surge in knife
crime in the year to May 2018 there were
97 fatal stabbings and so the UK capital
has announced it will be one of many
cities around the world looking to
follow Scotland's example in the hope of
breaking the cycle of violence
you